So, here is how this looks to a machine learning person.
We're going to produce what's called a scatter plot.
And, for simplicity, I'll just use two features.
There's tempo and intensity.
And, tempo might go from relaxed to fast, and intensity, for
the time being, will be light or soaring.
So, the song, Let it Go is mid-range in tempo, but quite intense.
So, it would be a data point right over here.
In for those songs, you can extract those features.
And, each song becomes a dot in this two
dimensional diagram of tempo and intensity.
This is slow song, it's very intense.
And, this is a slow song that's just very light.
So, I'm adding here data points for many songs.
And, suppose, the green ones are the ones that Katie likes.
Where as the red ones over here, are the ones that she doesn't like.
Suppose we encounter a new song with features for
right over here, in the spectrum.
Just looking at the data itself, that Katie would like this song, or
doesn't like this song.
So, just check the box on the right for like, or don't like.